Oh going my name's welcome back to some
more of Kanna damn so we're going to
this no smoking area this door closed by
itself about that I was I had to replay
in this part and it scare the heck out
of me wanna oh [ __ ] me oh no you don't
you dare do that to was but it was good
here absolutely nothing all right I
activate the fuse box or he was what
happened I don't even know what the
fuck'd I was oh yeah
I knew it oh he took Mike oh don't don't
shoot me please
applix I went no but what
oh you spare my back oh yeah duh you
saved my life barrel its chair
no you can't be true the [ __ ] hat what I
want my gun back I'm sorry oh you need a
weapon grab a pipe or some Dutch tape
give me that [ __ ]
please I need something to kill with
boxes no you're not deadly can I jump
over here I can move it
grab a pipe or a to learn oh cool maybe
over here whoa sup hi hi are you doing
dr. D ah I used to follow no I am
insulative I make no sense ain't up
Eddie okay
hey I like some I'm sorry I can't I
can't mimic that Sam that's a gay pipe
sham a paid preparer
what the hell is he
a good climber that it whoa
what are they doing upstairs they're
like I want to investigate but there's
no sharp it's a Shack oh all right back
up what are you doing to the lamb that's
not cool
oh hi please I just can't we be friends
why can't we be friends
are they gone wait I just walked through
that [ __ ] wall with that
da [ __ ] hey come oh I can block it in a
grouch
No all right whoa Wow please oh why is
he okay he's gone
I can't fight them anyway I'm so
hopeless which way in there
gasps victim at it since this rats rats
ass break glass oh you better believe
I'm doing that [ __ ] give me some of that
good stuff
I guess we'd go upstairs I did did it
today today goddamn be bad what's going
on you have to be bad they don't that be
their ass multi-bear sham apples we
tp'ed bear what's happened ah now you're
an explosion I find prepare say hi it's
just a huge box shorted I seem to be
trapped over here and I believe the
suspect has my gun Oh God
oh hell did that happen inside pip s5
what oh this fire accent rank your way
don't switch me with oh hey
sorry Pig bad see you later you can use
things like an axe or in a sledgehammer
as a weapon huh come a great deal of
damage but this slow so we need to let
pipe busts heads faster if that's what
you prefer Thanks
yeah you need the tip whoa Becker and
I'll go around the other way
try and stay in one piece doesn't work
at all it's time important thing if you
find yourself in a sticky situation I'll
use your taser the time of tasing by
night but you'll find it a great way to
disarm the slug of his weapon and I am
in how do I use it
present mouse button - oh good okay so
I'm supposed to go in here no hi whoa Oh
use fire axe cool ha
here's bear oh you're going down [ __ ]
oh that's right
thanks my ox ice pick job now what is it
taste that's right just get right in
your [ __ ]
I don't need bolts I don't need any of
that [ __ ] what's going on in here no I
want I don't want to prepare right now I
want to ask nice deirdre nice [ __ ]
bring it
okay let's go away having a weapon side
comparison all right I don't know what
that means
that's okay hello anybody out there
knowing you will blog it's vital well
come what's going on here did I get him
are you okay keep going huh throw here
love that love what they did to this
place it's really nice
Oh back off I have a Taser I swear to
god I'll take you just took me back
give me back why would he do that oh
you're serious you don't think I can see
you so stiff come on
whoa No where did he come from
I'll deal with you first no no no no
that's right you like that [ __ ] axe
knees to the face that's right
you got no feet by now oh no I want to
finish him off goddamn it all right
maybe I'll do it to this guy [ __ ] yeah
don't know I wanted to finish him all
right over one of these days I'll do it
for sure so first we must go in here
that's going everyone oh good night one
of those nice
I don't know what I think about okay the
slugs know I like you that's right and
here comes of justice I heard someone
else where whoa what are you doing is
teasing me no me gusta I'm out of here
huh huh walking whoa what are you doing
here no I want techniques that's right
well yeah teasing me with a fire haha
there we go and then a kick karate kick
communicate whoa what was that
hello how the door is open now to be on
this end of the gum I don't like it I
swear to god I'm sorry bastard give me
kiss don't why would i say this we are
both on the same damn it I don't know if
X needs any month to take this happens
tourney's please why he's got to do what
you got to do salsa
don't you can ah be ready for defin
pagent Tomas oh I'm ready made help come
visit him again no I'm not ready I'm
just kidding Wow why would you advance
me all right
whoa well favorite laugh better do your
dread knees
successful kills well that's not bad
alright I will have changes here Brad
okay enjoy like and fish I've had my
feet this much got that alright we know
it has to pretty jumpy scares now at
least but anyway like a beverage enjoy
subscribe to come Road today and I'll
see you next X that's pretty much it
[Music]
oh my god that's right that's how I roll